hey reject nation how y'all doing
I'm Greg Alba John's me John's me is
over here with us today we're gonna
continue our little segment of trailers
revisited BC guys don't know what this
is we look at trailers for films that
we've already seen and determined how
spoiler if ik it is what the tone is all
those things just it's like an
examination analysis of a trailer real
fun way since we're getting ready to go
watch ready player one right now that US
youtubers would check out Jurassic Park
because it's gonna be 25 years I think
or something or saddle 20 if they're 25
before we do that I also wanted to say
happy birthday it's David Gandy we just
got off a Google hangout with the guy
love that handsome gentleman and
speaking of patreon thank you to
everyone who's been joining us in this
month of March it's been so much fun
over there posting a lot we do weekly
Q&A s we do we take a question from
patron to a full-length video response
to it and we also do full-length TV show
reactions watch along so I cover on my
own attack on tied in catching up on the
flash Jon's n he does Runaways and
Riverdale and it landing a little bit of
Atlanta right now and together we are
covering my hero academia black
lightning we're still continuing Jessica
Jones as a lot of shows were checking
out would love to have you guys join us
to think for everyone watching along
with us not being around the bush let's
get to this running
damn welcome to Jurassic we've made so
astounding but they capture the
imagination of the entire planet the
most phenomenal discovery of our time
becomes the greatest adventure of all
time Universal Pictures presents
[Music]
give jurassic park back online
sixty-five years in the making
Jurassic Park
[Music]
yeah what's fascinating about this
trailer what in a minutes time span I
can't me and you got it you got a admit
yes day before you were born Humpty
Dumpty yeah it feels like a 90s trailer
for the most part captures the tone of
the movie yeah it's pretty surprising
like one minute time frame yeah you get
all the Wonder and the diversity trailer
because the movie has a pretty good
midpoint oh now it's like a horror
suspenseful movie yeah it's a creature
feature yeah the trailer communicates
that oh no or it's gonna be like
wonderful and then the last half of this
trailer is like shits gonna get real
intense in this [ __ ] right now yeah one
going back when I saw this and they
re-released it in 3d I'd sort of
forgotten just how intense parts of that
movie are like when I was a kid I was
mostly concerned with like how cool the
dinosaurs were and then as I got older I
realized that Jurassic Park it's kind of
a horror movie at its core when the poop
hits the fan it is it's like a build-up
to the horror however some of the
impression that trailers back then would
actually ruin movies more in some ways
this doesn't ruin like anything really
other than the fact that dinosaurs gonna
break out is this telling you the plot
of the movie there's smart cuz they're
showing you a lot of reaction shots on
the people yeah and that goes to support
both you know the the sense of wonder in
the first half and the sense of suspense
in the second half you know and you get
a taste for who all your cast is even
the trailer voice stuff things that get
you pretty excited like that's a cool
tagline 65 million years it's maybe
that's a cool tagline yeah for like the
introduction of a new era to see
dinosaurs on the big screen because I
know there's been movies I've done like
claymation ones before or whatever but
for this caliber this was a very unique
and exciting time to groundbreaker yeah
there's a groundbreaker of a time and
they also don't show you like anyone who
dies in the trailer they don't give away
any fun surprises and I can't help but
think of like bitter
cick world - first trailer for if maybe
most of that is from like the first half
hour 40 minutes sure but it still gives
away when they're about to get eaten and
then the t-rex shows up and I feel like
they're still show you so much and then
even in the part to the second trailer
for fallen Kingdom shows you so much
that's going on and this is the first
movie where you think they would have to
communicate a lot to you but this they
did it so efficiently here I'm so
fascinated by how they do this all in
one minute yeah yeah and I mean you know
today it's kind of fascinating to look
at what fandom has done to the way
movies are marketed and what you can
tell that they're pitching and maybe
even pandering to nowadays you think
like okay they're cramming this in with
a bunch of like questions they probably
know that we have and they're trying to
excite us based on these oh [ __ ] moments
yeah something like this yeah goes to
show you that if you just portray the
basic concept and the tone the right way
that's that's really all you need yeah
you know I feel like if this movie came
out now you could still do a similar
kind of trailer and just maybe make it
like 30 to 40 seconds longer but the
moments play out a little more there's a
lot to forgive here in the one minute
time because it's a 90s trailer but for
like an early nineties you're like this
is done pretty well like a modern-day
version of this trailer would only be
like less than a minute longer yeah just
to let some things smooth out and play
out as opposed to like a lot of rush
images but for what it is this is a
great trailer yeah and I just appreciate
that it's not the bullet points of the
story no they don't tell you anything
yeah you just know that it's probably
gonna go wrong and you could probably
surmise that that was gonna happen
anyway and even looking at this in bad
quality I'm like damn the effects still
look great I feel like even for the
trailers that we revisit that were like
good trailer we usually have like a lot
more things we could kind of pinpoint
but I'm like no that's true did
everything got the tone right see the
set up perfectly and then it leaves so
much details to to be left for wooden
for the viewing experience I'm like I
would have watched this just like that
arguably from all the trailers revisited
we've done yeah this is the one room
like yeah they nailed everything small
or anything you know and at a cool
minute
like this that's really all you needed
Wow but not that necessarily every movie
can get it accidents happens like
trailers today cuz you know trailers are
funny and every decade every generation
has its own version of giving away too
much or just doing the bullet points or
you know the occasional one that does
just kind of encapsulate the themes and
the tone and leave you with that my
trailers have definitely changed a whole
lot I mean and this also came out at a
time when there wasn't the internet
where you could like let's break down
every moment of the trailer yeah you
weren't pausing everything and looking
for Easter eggs trying to figure out how
it all plays out there were maybe
slightly less movies dependent on your
knowledge of other movies the worst
thing it possibly spoils is those amnio
and the kids are gonna be on their own
probably after this big t-rex attack but
I'm like that's just the plot of the
movie though that's like a setup for the
adventure you know
looks like Wayne Knights in trouble I
was genuinely surprised by how
efficiently well communicated this
trailer did it we need trailers to be a
little bit more like this nowadays
people take note all right guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification better get notified
every time one of our vids is up and you
could check us out on patreon like we
said all the [ __ ] we have over there
exists love to have you and happy
birthday again today begins in either